our education system is just in tatters
okay let's just be real about this our
public education system
sucks it is not good the latest
indicator that our public education
system sucks
is on tuesday night the san francisco
school board voted to accept the
recommendations of a renaming committee
is according to emily's audi at daily
wire
they voted to officially rename 44
public schools in san francisco bearing
the names of controversial historical
figures
these figures include abraham lincoln
george washington
theodore roosevelt franklin delano
roosevelt herbert hoover
paul revere thomas edison and senator
dianne feinstein
who was once the mayor of san francisco
san francisco commissioned the renaming
committee in october of 2019
they announced they were putting in the
committee's name change recommendations
to a vote in december and they kept
claiming oh you know it's just a
recommendation we're not going to do
anything well
then they did it then they did it so
what is the big problem with uh
feinstein so according to a 1984 copy of
workers vanguard
quote unquote dixie feinstein raised a
confederate flag at san francisco civic
center while she was mayor of the city
and later replaced the flag after it was
pulled down by protesters
but it turns out that that was part of a
historical flags display
and it wasn't clear that feinstein had
anything to do with it doesn't matter
her name comes off the high schools
abraham lincoln ran a fellow of the
committee because he did not demonstrate
that black lives mattered to him
that's a hot take there san francisco
abraham lincoln
you know the man who uh was shot to
death in a theater after
ending the civil war and issuing the
emancipation proclamation
he he didn't believe that black lives
matter solid take there san francisco
really well done really what they should
have just gone with
is that he was a homophobe and here's
the thing you could use that for like
everyone including barack obama up to
like 2011.
it's good you can just we should just
rename all of the schools every single
school
in favor uh we need to find the locust
person and that person all the schools
will be named after
i'm talking about we need like a
one-quarter black
one-quarter native american one-quarter
south american one-quarter chinese
little person transgender pansexual
that's what we need we'll find that
person and that person will name all of
the high schools after
we don't know who that is yet but could
be you it could be your lucky day if you
are that person if i just described you
please send your application in
to the san francisco school board
according to the san francisco chronicle
many san francisco parents
as well as mayor london breed argued the
effort was ill-timed given the pandemic
oh yeah it's just the bad timing that's
the problem by the way the move is gonna
cost san francisco's school district
millions of bucks because they actually
have to go through and rename all of
this
but what does money matter in schooling
after all i mean one one thing that we
definitely know
is that when it comes to schooling it's
the teachers unions who rule the roost
over in chicago they've got disaster on
that on the mind chicago public schools
has now directed parents to keep their
students home again on thursday
because the chicago's teacher union is
moving closer to a strike by the way
that's illegal
as far as i'm aware cps said in an email
to parents on wednesday evening quote
chicago teachers union leadership
continues to direct their members who
support pre-k and cluster programs to
remain at home
therefore we must we must ask parents to
continue keeping your children home
as we are unable to guarantee adequate
staffing levels to cover in-person
learning the district will continue with
remote learning tomorrow
on january 28th so good news they're
just going to keep these teachers out
forever the teachers have decided that
they don't want to work anymore
and yes that makes you selfish it does
if you decide that you want to take
public pay
and not work and you're 20 years old and
at very little risk of covered and it
turns out that you're teaching
kindergartners who aren't transmitting
it
that makes you a bad person it does i
hate to break it to you and just because
you're a teacher if
you're not teaching you're no longer a
teacher if you're not doing the job of
teaching i cannot call you a teacher at
this point i can just call you a leech
off the public taxpayer dollar
okay unless you are somebody who is
supremely vulnerable to coven
again if you are a young dance teacher
who is not going in
to to dance away the hours of first
graders
because of covid you're just lying okay
it's not about your risk
it is about the fact that you prefer to
stay home and and watch old episodes
on hgtv that that's that's all that's
going on right now
it's absurd and it has nothing to do
with the good of students obviously it
is anti-science naturally
uh the biden administration is doing
nothing about it nor are they even
sounding off about it
and you're you're gonna start to see a
parent's uprising here
if democrats don't create some gap
between them and these
god-awful teachers unions parents are
going to start saying you know what i'm
not going to vote for the party that's
in hot to these folks
here for example is a frustrated
virginia parent saying that school board
cowards who are not reopening our
schools they're hiding behind children
but they're not doing this for the kids
they're doing this for themselves
you're a bunch of cowards hiding behind
our children as an excuse for keeping
schools closed
you think you're some sort of martyrs
because of the decisions you're making
when the statistics
do not lie that the vast majority of the
population is not at risk from this
virus
the garbage workers who pick up my
freaking trash
risk their lives every day more than
anyone in this school system hey
tactic true faction true facts don't
care about your feelings and it's a fact
that the ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content